สวัสดีค่ะครูนิกสวัสดีครับครูเรียมวันนี้
วันนี้วันอะไรคะครูนิกวันนี้วันอะไรวัน
นี้วันที่นี่นะที่ครูนิกอยู่นะครับวันนี้
วันพุธวันพุธวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันพุธที่ 28
ครับอืเดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กันยายนปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 อืแล้วปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ครับอืกี่โมงแล้วคะครูนิกตอนนี้นะ
ครับเมืองที่ครูนิกอยู่เนี่ยเวลา
20:37 น
20  37 นาทีใช่โอ้โหอากาศวันนี้เป็นยัง
ไงบ้างคะครูนิตอนนี้เนี่ยอากาศเย็นครับ
เพราะว่ามันหมดหน้าร้อนละคือตอนนี้เค้าก็
เรียกว่าเป็นเหมือนใบไม้ผลิอใช่อากาศมัน
ก็จะเย็นแล้วก็จะเริ่มเห็นใบไม้เปลี่ยนสี
จากสีเขียวเป็นสีส้มสีเหลืองแล้วก็ผลิก็
คือเอ้ยไม่ใช่สิไม่ใช่ใบไม้ผลิใใบไม้ร่วง
อใช่ใบไม้ร่วงเป็นฤดูใบไม้ร่วงแล้วมันก็
จะ
ร่วงลงมาก่อนหิมะจะมาหน้าน่ะอ๋อก็คือ
กำลังจะอยู่ในช่วงเปลี่ยนไปเป็นฤดูหนาว
ที่หิมะจะตกใช่แต่ของเมืองที่คุณนิกอยู่
เนี่ย
เอ่อฤดูหนาวเนี่ยจะอยู่ประมาณจะเริ่ม
ประมาณคริสต์มาสช่วงธันวาคม
อ๋อแล้วช่วงนี้เกิดพายุบ่อยมั้คะครูนิ
จริงๆเนี่ยเมืองที่คุณคุนิกอยู่เนี่ยไม่
ยังไม่มีพายุคือมันมีพายุแต่ว่ามันมีพายุ
ผ่านมาบ้างแต่มันไม่ได้ผ่านมาเมืองที่ของ
คูนิอยู่อืก็เมื่อวันอาทิตย์วันอาทิตย์มี
พายุเข้าแต่ว่ามันผ่านมานิดเดียวก็แค่ฝน
ตกแรงประมาณครึ่งชั่วโมงแบบตกเยอะมาก
ครึ่งชั่วโมงแล้วมันก็ลงไปตอนใต้ของของ
รัฐที่ครูนิกอยู่อืแล้วเกิดอะไรขึ้นคะแบบ
ครูนิกฝนตกฝนตกแรงฝนตกหนักประมาณครึ่ง
ชั่วโมงอืแบบมีอะไรเกิดขึ้นมไม่ทำไม่ทำ
ให้น้ำท่วมใช่มยเออน้ำไม่ท่วมที่นี่เนี่ย
ที่นี่ไม่เห็นน้ำท่วมไม่ค่อยเห็นดีกว่า
คือคุณนิกเห็นต้องขับรถไปประมาณ 5-10
นาทีก็จะมีบางที่ที่เขาเหมือนกับเป็นถนน
ถนนแล้วมีเหมือนเป็นทุ่งนานิดหน่อยมันก็
จะมีน้ำขึ้นมาแต่มันไม่เยอะแต่แถวบ้านของ
ครูนิกเนี่ยไม่มีน้ำท่วมตรงบ้านที่อยู่นะ
เหมือนเป็นหมู่บ้านใช่ไม่มีน้ำท่วมอก็คือ
ช่วงนี้ที่เมืองที่ครูนิกอยู่ก็ไม่ได้มี
พายุอะไรหนักใช่
มยไม่มีครับใช่ไม่มีธรรมดาก็ไม่ค่อยมี
อยู่แล้วธรรมดาเนี่ยเมืองที่คครูนิกอยู่
เนี่ยจะไม่ค่อยมีพายุฝนแต่พายุหิมะเนี่ย
มีจริงหรอแบบเรียมไม่เคยเห็นหิมะเลยนะ
แล้วครูนิกเล่าให้ฟังได้มั้ยว่าพายุหิมะ
มันเป็นยังไงก็
คือปกติเนี่ยคือฤดูหนาวเนี่ยหน้าหนาวที่
เนี่ยมันก็จะมีหิมะตกธรรมดาหิมะตกเนี่ย
จริงๆแล้วเราก็ออกไปข้างนอกได้เดินธรรมดา
ได้แต่อากาศมันหนาวนะแล้วหนาวแบบนี้
คือติดลบประมาณติดลบประมาณเท่าไหร่ค่ะคือ
ถ้าจำไม่ผิดเมื่อฤดูหนาวที่ผ่านมาตอนต้น
ปีนะครับหนาวที่สุดเนี่ยติดลบ
15  15 องศเซซ
ใช่
โหแล้วแบบออกไปข้างนอกได้ไหมคะรูิออกไป
ได้ครับก็
คือมันติด-บ 15 องศาแต่เราก็มีใส่เสื้อ
กันหนาวแล้วก็คืออากาศหนาวเนี่ยไม่เป็นไร
ถ้ามันไม่มีลม
อืมันก็ออกไปได้ถ้าเราใส่เสื้อแบบ 3-4
ชั้นคือใส่เสื้อยืดเสื้อใส่เสื้อยืด 2
ชั้นแล้วก็มีเสื้อแขนยาวแล้วก็เสื้อกัน
หนาวมันก็โอเคแล้วถ้าวันไหนที่แบบ
อุณหภูมิติด -15 องษาหิมะตกแล้วก็มีลม
ด้วยมันจะเป็นยังไงค่ะอมันก็อาจ
จะไปทำงานได้อจะไม่ค่อยโอเคเท่าไหร่นะคือ
มันก็มีคือแฟนของครูนิกเนี่ยบอกว่ามันเคย
มีติดลบแบบ 20 องศาหรือติดลบ 25 องศา
ใช่คือพายุหิมะเนี่ยคือปีที่แล้วไม่ใช่ปี
ที่แล้วสิปีนี้ปีนี้เนี่ยมีพายุหิมะตอน
กุมภาพันธ์
แล้วมันเป็นพายุหิมะที่มันอันตรายเพราะ
ว่าเมืองที่คุณนิกอยู่เนี่ยในรัฐที่คุณ
นิกอยู่มันอยู่ตอนบนของอเมริกาแล้วอากาศ
มันจะหนาวอยู่แล้วมันเป็นหิมะปกติถ้าหิมะ
ตกธรรมดามันก็เหมือนเป็นแบบเวลาเราเห็นใน
ช่องแช่แข็งช่องฟีดอ่ะอืมองแบบนั้นเลยมัน
ก็จะตกลงมาช้าๆคนก็เลยจะชอบออกไปเล่นหิมะ
กันในเหมือนในหนังในการ์ตูนแบบนั้นแต่ถ้า
มันตกแรงๆเป็นพายุเนี่ยก็คือที่ครูนิกเคย
เห็นมันจะมีหิมะแล้วลมพัดแรงแบบนั้นน่ะ
เราก็จะเรียกว่าเป็นพายุเพราะลมมันแรงเรา
จะเห็นหิมะแบบหนาเยอะมากออกไปข้างนอก
อันตรายใช่อืก็เคยเจอทีนมาตกหนักเลย
เนี่ยมันก็หนา
ประมาณหนากว่าคือพอมันหยุดตกใช่มั้ยออกไป
ข้างนอกเนี่ยมันก็สูงประมาณนี้นะสูงมาก
กว่านี้ด้วยซ้ำบางครั้งใช่
อือืดีแล้วแหละที่ยังไม่เจอพายุที่แรงมาก
กว่านี้ใช่อืแต่ตอนนี้ที่ประเทศไทยค่ะมี
พายุเข้าแล้วสิ่งที่แบบเราแบบพิมพ์ข้อ
ความในโทรศัพท์หากันเจะมีคนถามเรียนมา
เยอะมากว่าที่บ้านฝนตกหนักมั้ยอืฝนตกหนัก
หรือเปล่าครับเรียมก็บอกไปว่าที่บ้านของ
เรียมก็ตกไม่หนักนะตกปอยลอยแต่
ว่าแต่ว่าตกทั้งวันไม่รู้สิแบบเมื่อวาน
แบบไปตากฝนมาออกไปนอกบ้านแล้วแบบเรียมขับ
มอเตอร์ไซค์ออกไปคิดว่าฝนหยุดตกแล้วครับ
คิดว่าฝนหยุดแต่ว่าฟ้าก็ยังมีเมฆเยอะอยู่
นะก็ขึมๆขับมอเตอร์ไซค์ออกไปกินข้าวตอน
กลับมาก็แบบตากฝนขับรถตากฝนก็คือแบบอืฝน
ตกฝนตกเปียกผมเปียกเสื้อเปียก
ครับแต่ที่ไทยเนี่ย
คืออันเนี้ยคุณนิก็สงสัยเหมือนกัน
เพราะได้ได้ยินตั้งแต่เด็กๆอืพ่อแม่พี่
สาวบอกว่าถ้าฝนตกปลอยๆเนี่ยแบบตกไม่หนัก
ตกเบาๆห้ามออกไปข้างนอกเพราะเราจะไม่สบาย
อืเพราะเขาบอกว่าถ้าฝนตกปลอยๆเนี่ยจะไม่
สบายเร็วกว่าฝนตกหนัก
อ๋ออันนี้ไม่รู้แคู่มาคิดครูนิกก็มาคิด
ว่าทำไมครูนิกเดานะเพราะครูนิกก็ไม่เคยหา
Google เขาบอกคุณนิคิดว่าเพราะละอองฝน
เนี่ยพอมันลงมาเบาๆเนี่ยมันอาจจะเพราะเรา
ไม่ได้รู้สึกว่ามันเป็นฝนตกหนักพอเราไม่
ได้คิดว่าเออไม่เป็นไรก็ปล่อยไปเดี๋ยวมัน
ก็แห้งแต่กลายแต่มันกลายเป็นว่าละอองฝน
เนี่ยมันซึมเข้าไปทำให้เราอ่ะเป็นหวัด
ง่ายไม่สบายง่ายออแต่ถ้าเราเดินฝนตกหนัก
ตัวเราแบบฉ่ำเลยเียใช่พออย่างแรกเราคิด
เมื่อไปถึงบ้านเราจะเปลี่ยนเสื้อผ้าใช่
เราจะไม่ปล่อยให้ตัวเราแห้งเหมือนฝนตกปอย
ๆอ๋อเออๆอาจจะใช่เพราะว่าเมื่อวานนี้
เรียมกลับเข้ามาเรียมก็มานั่งสอนกับครู
ฟ้าต่อเลยแล้วเรียมก็บอกไม่เป็นไรเปียก
นิดหน่อยผมเปียกเสื้อเปียกนิดหน่อยเออก็
เลยแบบรู้สึกว่าอืตอนนี้มีอาการนิดหน่อย
แต่ไม่ได้เป็นอะไรนะ
อืมนั่นแหละตอนนี้ก็ที่ประเทศไทยถ้าหลายๆ
คนอยู่ประเทศไทยตอนนี้นะคะก็จะเห็นว่า
ท้องฟ้าครึ้มครูนิกมีเพื่อนครูนิกส่งรูป
ให้ดูมยที่กรุงเทพฯอ่ะที่มันเป็นแบบก้อน
เมฆสีดำๆอ่ะมีมยแบบยังไม่มีแต่ว่าคครูนิก
อ่ะเคยเห็นครุณนิกเห็นในข่าวเพราะว่า
อาทิตย์ที่แล้วครูนิกดูขดูข่าวในกรุงเทพฯ
เหมือนกับมีน้ำท่วมฝนตกหนักแล้วมันเมฆมัน
เทาๆทั้งวันเลยใช่ๆเรียมเห็นน่ะแบบมีก้อน
เมฆอย่างเงี้ยอืแล้วข้างล่างเนี่ยเป็น
กรุงเทพฯอืจากตอนกลางวัน
น่ะกลายเป็นตอนกลางคืนเลยเพราะว่าแบบมัน
แบบอเมฆมันดำมากตรงเนี้ยดำ
มากแบบน่ากลัวอ่ะ
ใช่เวลา
โอ๊ะชนโต๊ะเป็นอะไรหรือเปล่าเมื่อกี้ข้อ
ศอกมันไปโดนโต๊ะ
อืก็จริงๆคุณนิแต่ครูนิกอ่ะเอาจริงๆอ่ะ
ครูนิกชอบเวลาฟ้ามันสีเทาเวลาฟ้ามันบืดๆ
ทำไมคะมันเป็นยังไงคือเพราะจริงๆแล้ว
เนี่ยส่วนตัวคุนิเนี่ยคุณนิก็ชอบอากาศ
หนาวแล้วพอุนิกเห็นฟ้ามันมืดๆฟ้ามันสีเทา
มันครึ้มเนี่ยคุนิกก็แโอเคลมเย็นละ
อืลมเย็นเพราะเหมือนฝนกำลังจะตกเออฝน
กำลังจะตกแล้วโอเคเราจะได้เปิดหน้าต่างรอ
ละลมมันจะได้พัดเข้า
มาเวลาเวลาอยู่ที่กรุงเทพฯนะเพบกรุงเทพฯ
อากาศมันร้อนอืใช่ค่ะแล้วพายุส่วนใหญ่ก็
จะเป็นพายุฝนใช่ใช่รูิเคยอยู่ในช่วงไหน
มั้ยของประเทศไทยที่มีพายุแล้วก็แบบเรา
รู้สึกว่าเออมันน่ากลัวมากมีมั้ยอืมเคย
มั้ยจริงๆเคยเคยตอนเด็กๆก็คือฝนตกหนักมาก
แล้วก็ฟ้าร้องจนไฟที่บ้านดับ
อืม
อืมฟ้าร้องฟ้าผ่าแล้วก็กำลังดูทีวีกำลัง
กินข้าวแล้วอยู่ดีๆไฟที่บ้านมันก็ดับมืด
ทั้งบ้านเลยโทรโทรทัศน์ก็ดูอยู่แล้วมันก็
ดับหายไปเลยใช่หแต่ไม่ได้มีแบบอะไรที่
ร้ายแรงกว่านี้แบบข้าวของพังอะไรอย่างงี้
มีมยไม่มีไม่มีก็ที่คุณนิกเจอท่าแรงที่
สุดก็แค่ไฟดับแล้วก็เป็นไฟดับที่คือบาง
ครั้งครับไฟดับเนี่ยมันก็จะดับแค่บางบ้าน
เพราะว่าตัว Cut  Out อ่ะมันตกเหมือนไฟ
มันตกแล้วก็แค่ไปเปลี่ยนมันก็หายแต่บาง
ครั้งเนี่ยมันดับทั้งหมู่บ้านมันดับทุก
บ้านที่อยู่ใกล้ๆแล้วถ้าเป็นแบบนั้นเนี่ย
เราทำอะไรไม่ได้ทำได้อย่างเดียวคือทำใจรอ
ว่าเดี๋ยวเขาก็ส่งไฟมาอืหรือบางทีก็ต้อง
แบบโทรบอกใช่มั้ยว่าที่บ้านไฟดับค่ะใช่
เค้าก็จะไปดูให้เพราะบางทีมันอยู่ที่เสา
ไฟหรือหม้อแปลงหม้อแปรงก็คือเหมือนกับ
เป็นไอ้
ตัวก้อนใหญ่ๆที่มันอยู่ตรงเสาไฟฟ้าไฟ้า
เออมันเป็นแบบเยแท่งๆใช่เดี๋ยวครูนิกดูซิ
ว่ามีรูปภาพมยเป็นหม้อใหญ่ๆเพราะว่าเพราะ
ว่าครูดิ๊กคิดว่าต่างประเทศตอนเนี้ยมัน
ไม่น่าจะมีแล้วเพราะว่าเา้าจะเหมือนกับ
เอาเสาไฟฟ้าเนี่ยสายไฟอยู่ใต้ดินอ๋อใต้
ดินอืแต่ของไทยก็เป็นแบบเค้าเรียกว่าอะไร
นะเป็นเป็นเหมือนที่ที่ต้องมาถ่ายรูปอ่ะ
เสาไฟฟ้าที่ประเทศไทยใช่ๆจริงๆอ่ะเดี๋ยว
เจอรูปละเหมือนยกตัวอย่างนะเหมือนกับ
อย่าง
เงี้ย
อคมีคนไปยืนโอภาพไม่ชัด
อืมเค้าจะเรียกว่าหม้อแปลงใช่มั้ยคะหม้อ
แปงใช่หม้อแปลงใช่หม้อแปลงไฟครับใช่ออคุณ
นิกแชร์หน้าจอไม่ได้น่ะอ๋อเดี๋ยวเรมเปิด
ให้คือคือเรียมเคยแบบมอบแรงนะเรียมว่าทุก
ที่อ่ะมันจะเหมือนแบบมันมีแรงดันไฟฟ้า
เยอะแล้วมันจะได้ยินเสียง
จใช่ใช่ตลอดเวลาอไม่รู้ครูเรียมเห็นมมย
เห็นค่ะเห็นใช่ไอ้ตัวเนี้ยครับเราคนไทยก็
จะเรียกว่าเป็นหม้อแปลงอืแล้วบางทีเนี่ย
พอฝนมันตกหนักเหมือนมันโดนน้ำเยอะๆฟ้าผ่า
อะไรหม้อแปลงมันระเบิดระเบิดตู้มเลยนะใช่
พอมันระเบิดตู้มอ้าวไฟดับตอนกลางวันน่ะ
ไม่เป็นไรเพราะว่าเราก็แค่ออกไปข้างนอกไป
ตากแอร์ในห้างอ
แต่ถ้าตอนกันครับครับมันจะมีเป็นไปได้
มั้ยที่ห้างไฟดับก็มีนะคุณนิเคยมีก็ถ้า
ห้างไฟดับแล้วก็ไปอีกห้าง
นึงนี้สุด
ยอดก็เราก็บอกเ้าก็ที่บ้านไฟดับเราหนีมา
ที่ห้างแล้วเพราะมันเย็นห้างนี้ไฟดับอีก
ก็ไปอีกห้างแล้วะกันใช่อืก็อยู่ในรถก็ได้
ก็เปิดแอร์ในรถเนี่ยปกคุณนิกไม่มีรถไง
หรือไม่ก็ไปซื้อตั๋วนั่งในรถไฟฟ้าครูนิก
รู้เลยว่าครูนิกชอบอากาศเย็นมาก
ๆใช่เพราะว่าเวลาครูนิกอยู่บ้านเนี่ยปกติ
ถ้าคุณนิกเปิดแอร์นะคุณนิกก็จะเปิดแอร์
ประมาณ
22 ถ้าเกิดเปิด 22 เหลี่ยมคือนอนทั้งวัน
น่ะแล้วก็นอนห่มผ้าห่มเออเพราะว่าคุณนิก
เนี่ยเป็นคนติดผ้าห่มถึงจะอากาศร้อนเนี่ย
คุณนิกก็ต้องห่มผ้าห่มมันก็เลยทำให้คุณ
นิกชอบอากาศหนาวเพราะอเปิดแอร์เนี่ยถ้า
เปิด 20  22 ห่มผ้าห่มมันก็โอเคอือ๋อโอเค
ส่วนตัวของเรียมเนี่ยเดมก็เจอพายุมาเยอะ
นะอาจจะอยู่ต่างจังหวัดด้วยแหละแล้วเป็น
อยู่ทางโซนอีสานถ้าจะเป็นพายุหนักๆก็จะ
เป็นพวกพายุที่มีฝนตกหนักๆนานหลายๆ
ชั่วโมงครับแล้วก็ที่แบบมันแย่ๆมากๆอ่ะก็
คือพายุที่มีลมอืมน่าจะเป็นพวกแบบพายุ
depression เออเหมือนเคยได้ยินเหมือนกัน
ครับใช่คนไทยก็จะเรกว่าเป็น depression
deess คนี้ก็ยังไม่เอืแต่ว่าแบบดีกว่า
พวกอะไรอะไรนะใต้ฝุ่นใต้ฝุ่นนี่จะหนัก
กว่าอแต่ส่วนใหญ่ก็จะแบบแค่ depression
แต่ depress ก็ทำให้บ้านพังแล้วนะออ
หลังคาบ้านน่ะหลังคาบ้านเปิดออกไปเลยบ้าน
เียอคยบ้านพ่อกับแม่คือเป็นบ้าน 2 ชั้น
บ้าน 2 ชั้นก็คือลงมาอยู่ชั้นที่ 1 อ๋อ
เพราะมันมีเหมือนกับเป็นเรียกว่าอะไร
เพดานใช่มั้ยเพราะมันเป็น 2 ชั้นเนาะใช่ๆ
ค่ะแล้วแบบหลังคาเปิดข้างบนบ้านคือเปียก
พื้นเปียกโอแล้วเอมันน่ากลัวมากแล้วซ่อม
นานมั้ยอ่ะถ้าเป็นแบบนั้นน่ะตอนนั้นน่ะ
ตอนนั้นหรอคะก็แบบใช้เวลาซ่อมอยู่ 2-3
วันออก็โอเคเพราะว่าบ้านหลังอื่นก็พัง
เหมือนกันอ๋อใช่เค้าก็เลยแบบจะให้ใครมา
ซ่อมก็แบบโอเคไปซ่อมบ้านหลังนี้ก่อนคือ
แบบอ๋ออืเพราะเวลามันมันพังเนี่ยก็คือแบบ
ไม่ใช่แค่บ้านของเราคนเดียวอืออ่าเป็น
บ้านคนอื่นด้วยอือฮึแต่ว่ายังไม่เคยเจอ
แบบตกจนน้ำท่วมบ้านไม่เคยอืคุณนิจำได้ว่า
แต่ตอนนั้นเนี่ยคุณนิกไม่ได้อยู่ที่
ประเทศไทยเพราะว่ามันเคยมีที่น้ำท่วมใน
กรุงเทพฯที่มันท่วมหนักมากๆแต่ตอนนั้นน่ะ
โชคดีว่าบ้านครูนิกเนี่ยมันน้ำไม่เข้าอื
คือมันน้ำมันก็ท่วมสูงแต่มันสูงแค่ถึงแบบ
ปริ่มๆอ่ะคืออีกนิดเดียวเนี่ยเกือบจะเข้า
ประตูบ้านละอูน้ำแบบระดับนี้หรอใช่คือ
เหมือนกับว่ามันก็ใช่สูงเหมือนกันครับก็
คืออันนี้เนี่ยได้ยินจากเพื่อนครูนิกเขา
บอกว่ามันก็ท่วมเยอะจนถึงหัวเข่าเลยนะ
โอถึงหัวเข่าก็จะแบบหัวเข่าเราอือืมก็
ท่วมเยอะจนบางคนเต้องขับรถอ่ะไปจอดบน
สะพานทงนสะพานทางด่วนไม่รู้จอดได้มั้ยนะ
ตอนตอนที่กรุงเทพฯฝนตกหนักจริงๆตอนที่
กรุงเทพฯน้ำท่วมเยอะจริงๆหลายคนเอารถไป
จอดบนทางด่วนนะเพราะว่าตอนนั้นก็คือขับรถ
ไปไหนไม่ได้แล้วใช่ๆคือครูนี้ก็จำได้ว่า
มีคนไปจอดบนแบบสะพานนหรือเป็นถนนสูงๆอ่ะ
แต่ก็ไม่ไม่แน่ใจว่าทางด่วนนะจอดได้หรือ
เปล่าแต่ก็คิดว่าน่าจะได้แหละเพราะตอนมัน
น้ำท่วมเยอะแล้วก็นานน่าจะหลายเดือนนะอื
ใช่ๆค่ะแต่หลายปีมาแล้วอืหลายปีแล้วน่าจะ
มากกว่า 10 ปีละเพราะถ้าจำไม่ผิดคิดคูนิ
ก็คิดว่าน่าจะเป็นตอนที่คุณนิไปที่
ออสเตรเลียมั้งครับตอนนั้นไปอยู่ที่
ออสเตรเลียประมาณ 1 ปีอืคิดว่าน่าจะแต่
ต้องระวังมากๆค่ะเวลาที่แบบฝนตกหนักน้ำ
ท่วมระวังเรื่องไฟช็อตอ่ะอไฟฟ้าช็อตอืใช่
่ครับอันตรายต้องต้องดูแลตัวเองเพราะช่วง
นี้อากาศมันก็เหมือนกับมีพายุน้ำท่วมก็
ต้องดูแลตัวเองด้วยเป็นหวัดใช่เดี๋ยวไป
กินยาดีกว่าตอนนี้ไปกินยาให้แบบรู้สึกดี
ขึ้นจะได้มั่นใจว่าจะไม่สบายอแต่แบบร่าง
กายยังแข็งแรงครับอืครูนิกก็กินครุณนิกก็
คือถ้าเวลาครุณนิกออกไปตากฝนเนี่ยกลับมา
บ้านเนี่ยเช็ดเช็ดตัวให้แห้งแล้วก็กินยา
คุณนิกชอบกินยากันเอาไว้เพราะไม่งั้น
เดี๋ยวเป็นหวัดแล้วมันไม่คุ้มต้องลางาน
ไม่มีเงินกินข้าวอีกอืม
โอเคแต่ว่าวันนี้เวลาหมดแล้วค่ะครูนิก
ครับออโอเคได้ๆเราต้องเจอกันในคลิปหน้าจะ
มีเรื่องอะไรมาเล่าให้ฟังต้องรอดูต้องรอ
ดูนะครับโอเคงั้นไว้เจอกันใหม่ครับครู
เหรี่ยมสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีครับบ๊ายบายบ๊าย
บาย